When it comes to sex, how long is too long?
Hello everyone and welcome to DNews, I’m
Dr. Crystal Dilworth here to discuss Intravaginal
Ejactulatory Latency Time.
Otherwise known as the time it takes a heterosexual
couples to have sex.
So how long “should” you be having sex
for anyway?
And are you…”normal”?
Well in attempting to answer these questions,
I discovered that “normal” has actually
changed with societal expectations, and the
average length of intercourse has varied over
time.
So it’s not just biology that we are dealing
with here.
How long we *think* we should be having sex
is an influence too.
In the late 1940s at the time of the famous
Kinsey Report, 75% of males surveyed reported
intercourse lasting approximately 2 minutes.
A number that seems objectionably short to
me personally and could warrant a premature
ejaculation diagnosis in these modern times.
For the record, the diagnosis of PE is heavily
weighted towards self and partner reported
satisfaction but one to two minutes is commonly
considered premature.
Researchers are finding that since the late
60’s, since the start of the feminist movement,
and sexual revolution, intercourse has been
taking us slightly longer.
How long?
Well survey data from studies done at the
University of New Brunswick show that duration
of vaginal intercourse is now reported to
fall within a range of 5 - 10 minutes, with
durations in excess of 20 minutes being undesirable
to most study participants.
So that average sweet spot is really, as one
scientist put it: “approximately the duration
of one Marvin Gaye song”.
Sadly, sex research is notoriously penis-centric
and historically hetero-centric, so these
averages only apply to the time it takes for
male ejaculation with a female partner and
only the more recent studies investigate qualitative
measures like sexual satisfaction.
In a 2004 study, participants were asked to
report how long they wanted sex to last as
well as the actual duration of their intercourse.
Female study participants indicated they desired
an average of 7 min longer intercourse then
what was standard with their current partners,
and men reported wanting another 11 min.
The funny thing about this survey, is that
when asked about duration of foreplay both
men and women also reported desiring an average
of 5 or 10 min longer respectively.
So, take a look at your partner.
Are they smiling?
If not, it might be time for a conversation
about sexual expectations and needs.
Because, ultimately, it doesn’t matter what
study group survey subjects think, or what
your friends, neighbors, or professionals
on your computer screens are doing, what matters
is self and partner satisfaction.
Something to keep in mind as you check out
this video where Julia asks the question “How
much sex should you be having?”
So, are you sexually normal?
Please subscribe to DNews and do NOT let us
know the answer to that question in the comments
down below.
What do you think?
Let us know in the comments below and keep
coming back to Testtube for brain tingling
science every day of the week.
Come find us on social media and let us know
what you think.
You can find us on Facebook at Discovery News
and on Twitter @DNews.
You can also find me @PolycrystalhD